winter is coming in it's making some of
us start to feel our age Game of Thrones
is back Season six I am back with my
episode by episode reviews this first
one's out a little later than I would
have planned but I blitz sick for a
little bit coming off of watching the
other one that wasn't up for it so this
is getting up late I will try and get
these up within a few hours of the
episode having aired and I'm no longer
doing spoiler free that's the big thing
I'm talking spoilers now just cuz it's
easier so with that said let's get
started with the woman in red we pick up
where you would expect to pick up which
is immediately following the death of
John well not immediately it's the next
morning but basically the discovery of
his body I think that was a really smart
place to start given that almost all the
speculation about the season hasn't been
about is he dead is he not now it is
pretty clear at this point he is dead
does that mean he won't come back well
no we are dealing with a world that
we've seen resurrection through various
means on a couple of different
characters maybe he'll still come back
but for right now he is dead he did die
and I like the whole thing with John's
very close friends basically kind of
banding together and being like we are
completely outnumbered by people who
either were in on betraying him or are
gonna go along with it because Sir
Alastair has taken power and I like that
Davos is mixed in with that group cuz I
just love him and I love any reason we
can have for him to stick around be an
active part of things going on I will
say I was really impressed with Sir
Alastair basically saying up front I
killed him here's why and even going so
far as to say I do believe Jon Snow did
what he thought was right but it would
have been the end of us so I was really
impressed with the handling of that they
didn't just make him cackling villain
I'm taking over it's like no he still
has to get these guys on his side he
still has to be a charismatic leader
type otherwise they're just gonna take
it out on him and it's gonna be an
instant revenge kill and they make it
believable that he could take control of
the situation
there's a surprising bit of humanizing
for a number of more or less villainous
carrot well more or less in the case of
Sir Alastair definitely in the case of
Ramsay because he gets introduced into
the season in a surprisingly human
moment basically morning the girl that
fian pushed off the wall now all too
this is still Ramsay he is still a dick
about it but at the same time like that
there is some semblance of something
slightly human under that which in a way
makes him even more monstrous because if
he were just the you know pillaging
raping I'm gonna cut you in two thing
he's easier to dismiss but when there's
a hint of humanity that somehow makes it
worse like maybe there's something that
could be saved but you don't care you're
just gonna be this horrible thing anyway
towards Theon and Sansa of course
they're alive I knew they were gonna be
and they're running away and
realistically they were not gonna get
away they were being hunted down with
dogs men on horseback they were never
gonna escape and they don't escape
instead they are rescued by someone who
it was already established was in the
area brand of Tarth
what a fantastic entrance for her into
that just riding in saving the day
Podrick gets an awesome kill even bran
she you know gets knocked down a bit she
does have to actually fight even though
she is the white knight riding in to
save the day she doesn't save it easily
she still has to do the work which is
part of what I love about her I love
that she has now found Sansa and she is
now going to finally get to fulfill part
of her pledge to Lady Stark which is to
protect the daughters and I'm just I'm
so happy for Brienne it makes me really
hopeful you know that's something good
will finally come of Sansa so I like all
that a lot what else we got King's
Landing Cersei and Jaime reunited and
pissed and rightfully so Jaime gets to
find out about what seriously went
through while he was gone seriously just
to find out that the daughter is dead
yeah they are they neither of them was
in a good place at the end of last
season and now they both got renewed
reason to just burn this place to the
ground and I kind of want to see him do
it we get a quick little same with
Margaery and we see the high Sparrow who
I love he's Jonathan price in this world
is so good because he just comes across
as so humble and even points out that
some of his all her followers are too
zealous but he's just so committed to
his belief in such a calm way it's
really disarming in a kind of
frightening way almost over him Braavos
well that blindness seems to be sticking
around pretty well but I like seeing the
other girl from the house of black and
white coming and it looks like basically
starting up for training here again
she's
going to through beating her with a
stick teacher to blind fight it looks
like she's just because she says I'll
see you tomorrow so this is gonna be a
recurrent thing to get Aria back sort of
up and ready to keep going again over in
Mereen not too much happens but we just
sort of get a reestablishment of the
situation which is not great for anybody
RIA really it's not complete chaos but
it's not really clear who's kind of in
control of what's going on and I really
like the vibe I'm getting off of Terry
because he really just feels like yeah
this place is a mess I'm gonna fix it
he's got this energy about him that you
feel like he's just gonna step up and
just do awesomeness or Andorran daughter
dawn was weird because I'm not sure why
it was there the thing is the time for
the Doran scenes before was how the the
sand snakes and that other woman who
wanted revenge against the Lannisters
and Jaime and Bronn you know trying to
get Jaime's daughter back and and but
that kind of all finished it kind of
wrapped up what went on there lessees
and didn't get me invested in the place
in and of itself so okay so there's a
coup and they killed the prince and most
of the guards seem to be on their side
and that's not uninteresting but I don't
think I care and I'm not sure why I'm
supposed to I'm not upset about it or
anything I'm just right now I don't care
and finally we've got Daenerys with the
Dothraki which is still just weird to me
I mean you know it gotta happen I guess
they just saw her and like yeah we'll
take her I like that she established you
know her Authority in her history right
off the bat but at the same time this
whole you know I would never touch a
cows Widow and you have to go off to
this other place I mean I'm sure I guess
you know it's an existing law and all
the rest of that but because this shows
been going on six seasons we never heard
it before it feels a bit kind of a deus
ex machina explanation oh thank goodness
there's this rule that will keep them
from ever molesting her again like well
good but you kind of pulled that one out
of your butt
and I'm just not in love with this whole
direction of her because it's bit it's
what it feels like we have been seeing
happen to Daenerys for most seasons
which is
just stalling stalling stalling stalling
roadblock after roadblock after
roadblock just to keep her from taking
the dragons and going across the stupid
say narrow see it's called the narrow
see it's not that big just get her on
the other side of it already like that
was a point when she was first building
up her forces first taking over slavers
Bay things like that I was like cool
awesome you shut her she's having
difficulty really okay I'm fine with
that but the whole time I'm like I want
her on the other side of that sea I want
her in Westeros I want her tearing stuff
up and you're still stalling I'll tell
you when she finally gets there it
better be epic because they have spent
so much time delaying that but oh this
is a pretty good start it establishes
all the stuff that needs to be
re-established it has enough stuff
moving for or at least sets us up for
what will be things moving forward then
it doesn't feel like an inner just a
reminder of everything going on episode
and most of the things that it seems to
be pointed to at least for the immediate
follow-ups of the next few episodes I
like it I'm digging some things feel
like wheel spinning I suppose the last
thing I shouldn't talk about is that can
last reveal with lady Melisandre which
was interesting I'm not sure I've got a
word for it besides that it does
definitely give me a completely
different perspective on her as a
character and I when i rewatch earlier
episodes now I've got a watch it looks
kind of a different eye in kind of a
different thought process which is the
kind of thing that a really good reveal
does it makes you re-evaluate a
character because before it just seemed
like well she's just power-hungry but
then you see truly not in words nobody's
to say it but you see fully represented
just how old she is yeah that that
changes your perspective like she's been
around long enough I don't think she'd
just be in this for power she has faith
she believes all this and she seems to
now be doubting that and in this one
stroke she has become much more
interesting to me as a character so yeah
well done so there's my thoughts on the
woman in red premier upper self a game
of Thrones what did you think about this
thing did you love it did you hate you
like some of you didn't like some of it
whatever you thought drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe follow me
on twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast at itunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned